this is just asking questions a show for
inquiring minds on
reason last week Argentina's newly
elected Libertarian president Javier M
gave quite the speech at the world
economic forum's annual conference in
Davos uh the speech drew a lot of
attention in the media and online at
least our corner of the social media
world because the world economic Forum
has earned a reputation as kind of the
ultimate Global Elite Clubhouse in a
world turning increasingly populist and
nationalist so where exactly does melay
fit into this new world for this episode
Liz and I wanted to go through his
speech together and try to figure that
out and we've invited Argentine
Argentine political scientist Marcos
Falcone who's project manager at
Argentina's fashan libertad to help us
out with that Marcos thanks for joining
us thank you Zach and Liz for the
invitation sure and you know before we
get into the speech itself I thought it
would be helpful to talk a little bit
about the world economic forum and uh
what it stands for what its goals are
and kind of talk about mle's presence at
that conference in in Davos um malle's
introduction was given by none other
than our favorite super villain esque
German Professor CLA Schwab founder of
the WF let's hear a little bit of uh
Schwab's
introduction it's for me a great great
honor to welcome Javier M as you know is
a freely elected president of Argentina
I think you sometimes people would say
with more radical methods but you
introduce a new spirit to
Argentina making
Argentina much more related to free
enterprise to entrepreneurial
activities also to bring Argentina back
to the rule of law so we have a very
extraordinary person among us today and
of course we are all eager uh to listen
to you and again a very cordial welcome
to the world economic
Forum all right so generally pretty
cordial mle is a he's radical but he's
bringing markets and the rule of law to
Argentina so maybe not all that bad the
WF is not
contrary to some of the theories out
there some sort of you know communist
organization they're not reflexively
hostile to markets they just in my view
uh look at them as tools to achieve
certain social ends because they're
corporatists um and I have to imagine
you know having watched the speech that
he was not expecting what happen next uh
because we'll see soon that Malay goes
directly for the jugular at of what the
WF is actually all about um or or maybe
he doesn't just he just doesn't care he
he's 85 years old maybe you know just
want to YOLO spice things up see what
happens any thoughts of Liz or Marcos
about just kind of the WF CLA Schwab
Davos I mean they're sort of cringe
technocratic Central planners um so I
have to believe that with the amount of
control they exert over the rest of us
surely they exerted lots of control over
preting the speeches which makes me
think that Malay went off script a
little bit um I don't know you know
whether or not that's true there's not
really any indication as to what
happened but that's sort of the only
explanation I can come up with that
explains how Malay got so delightfully
fiery uh in his speech in a way that is
sort of an indictment of some of the
things CLA Schwab stands
for what about you Marcos do the WF like
what do it what does it mean to you if
anything as someone who's living through
the economic turmoil in
Argentina um it doesn't really mean much
to me personally um but here in
Argentina there was a lot of expectation
about mle's speech particularly because
um of the of the idea that it could
mirror the speech that uh former bran
mree gave in 2016 when he took office
when he yeah he he had just taken office
like one month prior just like M uh and
back then this was like like the
reintroduction of Argentina into the
world stage right into the world of free
enterprise and so there was some
expectation as to um whether mle would
mirror that speech or or whether he
would go um Off Script as Li said
although it I mean we'll talk about the
speech later but the speech itself is
not that different from the speech that
we as argentines have been hearing um
consistently from laay in the past years
U it's remarkably similar to um lectures
that he has given out loud to whoever
would listen um in different cities in
the country I was actually part of one
of them um in my hometown Mar Plata in
the summer of I think it was 2023 last
year um he he was just just touring the
country you know and lecturing about
economics and freedom um and and some of
the contents of those lectures were
remarkably similar to the speech that we
saw at Davos so to what degree did this
actually mirror mri's
speech well
um I I would say that it did in that uh
they both favored uh free enterprise and
freedom in in you know on paper uh but
went after uh the the W um wef uh scores
values or not core values but many of
the interests that they have taken in in
past years uh in a way that makri did
not I mean makri was all for you know um
fighting climate change and and the
progressive agenda in terms of uh civil
liberties uh whereas mle was clearly uh
like he he opposed all of that he was
clearly against all of that so and he
was much more radical in arguing in
favor of capitalism because mockery
speech um resembled you know this idea
of Claus Schwab and others that um
capitalism is at the service of
something else you know that we value
capitalism because of the because it is
a means uh to to a different end whereas
mle argued in in my view at least that
capitalism is is good in itself because
it allows us to do whatever we want with
them which is not I think uh what the
world economic Forum stands for so in
that regard it did not mirror marer
speech there were similarities and
dissimilarities but um I think this this
was a much more radical speech which is
what I would expect from a Libertarian
uh and Anar capitalist president yeah
and that's why I think it's it is
important going into this to understand
uh the the values of the WF and and to
not get distracted by some of the
strange uh theories about the WF and I
I'll I'll not so humbly recommend uh one
of my previous videos on this called uh
forget the great reset Embrace The Great
Escape that I I that kind of lays out
what the WF is actually all about um
which is not uh necessarily A a like
nefarious um agenda to turn us all into
like transhuman AIS or something like
that but more so a kind of
manag a kind of managed version of
capitalism that has become known as
stakeholder capitalism where you uh in
you put aside kind of the previous like
Milton Freedman conception of capitalism
as just delivering value to the
shareholders of a company to expanding
the Mandate of a company to deliver uh
to so-called stakeholders which could be
um environmentalist groups or labor
groups or any other kind of interest
group that you could come up with here
at at domestically Elizabeth Warren has
been one of the outspoken proponents of
this she's uh proposed you know I think
40% worker ownership or worker
representation on corporate boards in
California there's been attempts to kind
of rebalance what a what a corporate
board looks like and so that's why I
ultimately describe them as corporatist
and I think in kind of the the furthest
the the most uh
extreme uh instantiation or examp
example of like where where this heads
would be China where they actually put
government uh you know party officials
on the corporate boards so the
stakeholder is actually the government
itself and that gets into you know
outright fascism so can lead to really
bad places China has like the opposite
of separation of state and business it's
all so disturbingly intermeal in a way
that I think a lot of Western audiences
just totally U
misunderstand yeah and uh in the at the
2022 Davos conference um xiin ping was
the kind of keynote speaker who kicked
off the conference and uh CLA gave him a
fairly glowing intr uction there as well
which I I found kind of disturbing but
um before we move into mle's speech uh
let's play one more clip just to get now
that I think we've laid out a little bit
of of what the WF is about and what
Davos is about um CLA Schwab actually is
on the record uh with his opinion about
Libertarians and where
libertarianism fits into the New World
Order uh so let's uh roll that clip from
the 2017 World Government Summit in
Dubai we are at historical
Crossroads we Face a
backlash of millions of people
particularly in the west who feels that
globalization is not working fixing the
present system is not
enough now there is of
course a anti system which is
called
libertarianism which means to tear down
everything which
creates some kind of influence of
government into private
lives it's Dem manling the system and we
see certain elements of this now in the
new US Administration if we want to go
forward we we need a completely new
thinking we have to integrate into our
future
policymaking is the
notion of
multistakeholder concept the big
challenges which we have cannot be
solved by governments alone but they
cannot be solved by business or Civil
Society alone we need new ways of
cooperation of very flexible cooperation
I wish you
a very
good World Government Summit thank
[Music]
you okay so yeah new flexible ways of
cooperation uh between public and
private that that's kind of what I was
alluding to earlier and then you know
his assertion that Libertarians are
anti- system which you know we are yeah
we are anti your system the one you're
selling to a bunch of monarchs in the
UAE I that leads you to open your
conferences with ODS to the wisdom of
xiin ping I I could not imagine a better
endorsement honestly but um you know we
again want to be really clear about what
the WF is and isn't um and you know e
even CLA uh Schwab uh has acknowledged
you know these these changes in that
these technological changes uh that have
driven political changes and made it
much harder to have top- down control so
he does at times talk about the need for
subsidiarity the the need to uh have you
know more localized versions of control
and um it he's he's not really at this
point advocating for some sort of One
World Government but more so that uh
local and National governments kind of
come in under the WF umbrella and kind
of we we have this common view of of
governance and these sort of common uh
tools and and consensus to kind of
manage the future uh but uh I just want
to open the floor to both of you for any
additional reactions to Claus's view of
libertarianism um I have a lot of
disdain for K Claus Schwab's description
of libertarianism I think first of all
Libertarians exist on this massive
glorious Spectrum there's obviously
rothbardian andap types who very much
hate the state and do want to smash the
system uh in a very major way there are
also I think on the other side of the
spectrum a bunch of Libertarians who
look at the current system which
involves an awful lot of crony
capitalism and subsidies dled out to uh
various companies that are sort of in
these bidding wars for contracts with
the government and they look at that and
they say why is it that anytime um
government sort of taints everything
that it touches uh you know anytime we
look at a project either done in Co
collaboration with a government or by a
government agency itself we see it
completed um you know two years later
than they had anticipated and massively
over budget in any other sector that
would be totally uh unacceptable and so
a lot of Libertarians look at the State
of Affairs at present and say well
government like look at the results
government is not in many cases
delivering to nearly the degree that
they say they will and to us that
indicates that we need to privatize more
things and allow markets to um you know
conduct more affairs than the government
the thing is Libertarians I think are so
frequently portrayed as these like naive
people who think that absolutely
everything will be perfectly solved once
we get the government out of the way and
I think Libertarians actually frequently
realize that there will be short-term
pain points in the same way that I think
Mal is sort of setting Argentina up for
realizing that that is what will happen
in order to get inflation under control
in the short term there will be massive
unemployment there will continue to be
people living you know 40% of the
country below the poverty line right
like that is not going away tomorrow but
he will move things in the right
direction and will pursue a means of
getting inflation under control and I
think Libertarians that's the thing that
people really miss so I think CL Schwab
is totally misrepresenting what
Libertarians stand for and a lot of the
critiques that we make and he's placing
an extraordinary amount of faith in
government collaboration as a thing that
uh you know creates efficiency uh and
creates good results and I think I'm
interested in what results he's looking
to because I don't see it yeah and cl I
mean uh mle as the first uh kind of
self-described elected libertarian head
of state is now starting to be a standin
for a lot of for you know the well I
guess we're going to start to see what
libertarian governance looks like for
the first time and you know you talked
about about all these different types
and strains of libertarianism Liz and
mle is an interesting blend of several
of these strains maybe a synthesis uh
and he's a practical anap right like he
is in what he actually believes an
anarcho capitalist uh and that yet he
also realizes that he actually must get
stuff done and that there will be a long
transition from the current system that
Argentina has to where he's looking to
go yeah you talk a little about that
Marcos the blend or the type of
libertarian that uh mle has been as a
sort of public intellectual and now is
as a elected politician or he he was an
elected politician before but elected he
State well he's definitely pragmatic uh
because when he was campaigning he was
all for uh well of course you know an
arc of capitalism
libertarianism um but now that he's
president um he doesn't talk publicly
that much I mean the davo speech was
actually one of the few instances in
which we have uh listened uh to M since
he became president the other important
time was when he took office and he
delivered the speech that was
um that was libertarian spirit in which
he also warned about uh not just
short-term or or or a bit of pain but he
warned a lot of pain because of the
situation uh in which the country
uh finds itself but but it's interesting
because this
this the the measures that m is
proposing through a decree first in late
sept uh late December now through a law
through an Omnibus Bill that is being
discussed in the House of
Representatives which we can talk about
later um are libertarian in some aspects
and in some aspects uh not so much right
so he he is pushing for deregulation
to a point that no prior government has
ever done um and that is extremely
positive and he's trying to go against
crony capitalism um and he's trying to
go against you know these corporatists
that say that they that they claim they
defend capitalism but they don't they
just defend their own businesses um and
in some aspects mle is just being
Orthodox you know and not that
libertarian but rather uh
classic conservative right like trying
to achieve for example um um a fiscal
balance Argentina in I mean he inherited
a fiscal deficit that that is pretty
high and he's now trying to reduce
public spending but also increase
taxation um so it's funny because he
claimed mle claimed before the election
that he would cut his arm before uh
sending before proposing proposing a tax
hike but his government actually is
proposing a tax hike right now so a tax
hike on who those are exports and
imports is that
right well yes on on many exports
although there's negotiation in Congress
uh which has eliminated uh these taxes
for some sectors uh but also today uh as
we speak uh the government is sending
out um a law uh on the income tax that
was repealed I think it was four months
ago with the votes of mle himself in
Congress while he was campaigning um the
government will is now trying to
reintroduce the income tax and of course
it's going to try and make it um much uh
I mean it's trying to make it less uh
costly for the families for individuals
but it is De it is definitely
reintroducing there's no way around it
um so that that's why I'm saying in many
aspects because I assume this is because
they are in such a fiscal hole right now
corre corre as you said dug by his
predecessors that they're doing
everything they can to balance that
budget and that in the shortterm at
least is going to require both raising
revenues and uh you know cutting
spending um correct have
we right like maybe he's making good on
his promises yeah see a one-armed
president no uh who knows um but but
that that's why the government is also
proposing that taxes go down after next
year uh after 2025 so that the country
stabilizes this year and the next year
uh the government can continue with the
with the with the downtrend in terms of
of Revenue but so far you know that
there's going to be pay he said they
would be paying um and well the the
unions are actually protesting today mes
got his first um general strike National
strike on Wednesday January 24th um only
40 days 40 less than 45 days after he
took office unions have uh never done
anything like this uh they waited for
five years before um striking with the
Christina kishner government for example
so yeah you can imagine that there's
going to be turmoil and protesting and
there definitely is what will this ACC
the protests in the streets I I want to
talk about this more later but I'm
curious like you know I was reading
about how it's some like 200,000 who are
expected to be protesting in the streets
of Buenos areis today um and obviously
people protesting all around other
Argentine cities but also like there's a
massive protest planned in like Berlin
for Argentine expats living there I know
New York City has protest planned where
I live San Francisco has protest right
like this is a massive thing but but
what does this do is it just this work
stoppage uh I mean I know unions have a
lot of power in Argentina but Marcos
what what's the effect going to
be yeah they basically uh try to prevent
workers from going to work so this is
why if if people who if demonstrators
find open um stores for example in
downtown buid is they will probably try
to force them to
close uh so it's kind of ridiculous the
government has actually um uh called I
mean the government um put in place a
phone line where people can denounce
whether they're being forced to uh stay
at home and not go to work uh by a union
representative and they claim that they
have received more than 60,000 reports
of people who have been threatened not
to go to work because the country needs
to strike against mle um so there's a
lot of violence involved uh implicit and
explicit in this strike but what they
try to accomplish is mostly symbolic I
would say uh since the Omnibus Bill is
scheduled to uh be uh well debated and
then possibly approved uh shortly they
want to show that there's uh unrest that
the people are against this law that the
law shouldn't pass that the decree that
L signed in late septe late December um
must be overturned by the courts uh and
they want to show the world and this is
why they they're also striking in San
Francisco New York Berlin Rome they want
to show the world how terrible You Know
M policies are which of course they're
not um but but this this is typical they
did this to mrie too even when mree uh
when mre's policies were were not as you
know as Pro capitalist as mes so why
wouldn't they do this to
mle people who protest yeah it's a
little bit of the same as the US
phenomenon which is where for years and
years uh whenever a presidential
election came around and it looked like
a republican was going to win Democrats
would claim this is the most important
election of your lifetime get out the
vote and so then finally when the Trump
phenomenon um sort of rose up they were
claiming this is the most important
election of your lifetime and I think a
lot of people meant it little bit more
but to some degree it's this Saga of the
boy who cried wolf where it's like you
already did this four years ago and
you're going to do this again in four
years and I'm just like on to the whole
routine of it and it seems like in
Argentina it's kind of the same thing
with how angry unions get and the degree
to which it's just regardless of whether
you're mrie or Malay they're going to
come out in full force and talk about I
was seeing some posters circulating that
were like oppose the IMF the the pro IMF
Zionist government of Malay and it's
just like what like really it's just
nonsense no as long as the government is
not parist they will protest that's what
they do I and we're we're going to dig
into some of the substance of mle's
legislative agenda and those decrees
near the end of the conversation but one
thing that um stood out to me in your
answer Marcos was you were talking about
the fact that mle has not been giving a
lot of public statements or speeches
since being elected I find that really
interesting
because it's like when Trump was elected
you know there's been a lot of
comparisons in the media between Trump
and melay which are largely ill-founded
but I think it's a lot of it's based on
their perceived temperaments and their
rhetorical style and there was this big
question mark after Trump was first
elected of like okay now that he's
president is he going to act differently
and the answer was no not at all melay
on the other hand uh seems like there is
a sort of pivot and maybe a seriousness
or or like Devotion to uh the mission
that W or Focus that that was not there
uh for Trump uh and so it's it's
interesting that his his fir one of his
first big speeches is is this one and
and I noticed in watching it that it was
also and people will see this as we
start to play the clips it seemed a
little more controlled I mean it was
very you know reading from a script um
he's not doing the fiery Malay thing
that we see on television clips from his
his campaign and before that uh so let
let's just get right into the speech and
and uh make some observations about both
the style and substance of what he's
saying so we'll we'll first run um his
opening
statement today I am present to inform
you that the Western world is facing a
sign significant
threat it is in danger because those who
are supposed to defend the values of the
western world are coopted by a worldview
that inevitably leads to socialism and
consequently to poverty and economic
deprivation
unfortunately like you said this this uh
and I should have mentioned this at the
top we are running a these clips are
actually an AI translated version of mle
that is meant to sound to approximate
the tenor of mle's voice so some clever
person ran the transcript through one of
these AI voice generators and uh created
this you know appro this this AI
approximation of mle's voice and that it
actually syns his mouth to uh the word
so this is a weird you know uh 2024
thing that we're doing here uh wanted to
disclaim that uh as as loudly and
forcefully as possible and mentioned
that as always we will link to our
sources uh and the original transcript
uh that you you can watch uh to but we
we did check and you know it's it's it's
accurate with the transcript that the WF
uh posted but we just thought for audio
and video purposes this would be like
the best way to consume this uh that
aside uh his opener there really is like
you said Marcos consistent with the
message we've heard over and over again
which is that there this is uh kind of
an existential battle between um
individualism and collectivism in all
its forms um any way in there before we
continue yeah no I just wanted to say I
think um if I'm not mistaken I think
Malay was photographed uh as he was
entering the plane that took him to
Davos with a copy of individual ISM and
economic order by
freek um so I think that tells you you
know about the the spirit that he wanted
to convey with that speech and he
did absolutely Liz anything else where
you want to keep going let's go I need
more M all right let's go in recent
decades motivated by some
well-intentioned desires to help others
and others by the desire to belong to a
privileged cast the main lead leaders of
the western world have abandoned the
model of freedom for different versions
of what we call
collectivism we are here to tell you
that collectivist experiments are never
the solution to the problems that
afflict the citizens of the world but
rather they are their
cause trust me there is no one better
than us argentines to provide testimony
on these two
issues when
when we Embrace freedom in 1860 in 35
years we became the world's first
dominant power 35 years we became the
first world power while when we embraced
collectivism over the past 100 years we
saw how our citizens began to
systematically impoverish themselves
until they fell to the 140th position in
the world 40 in the world but before we
can have this discussion it would be
important for us to First Look at the
date
that supports why free market capitalism
is not only a possible system to end
World poverty but also the only morally
desirable system to achieve
it okay so he's saying that the Arc of
Argentina's history there is sort of a a
case study in what happens when you
Embrace and turn away from free market
capitalism would you be able to flesh
out a little bit of that political and
economic history for us mar mar just
give us the last like 200 years of like
your
country like two minutes right yeah yeah
great thank you well but but mle is
right in that Argentina is a a sadly
remarkable example of what happens when
you uh steer away from capitalism and
free markets uh
Argentina um back in the in the late n
in the late 19th century was a among the
top economies of the world um it was
second only to the US um in terms of the
countries that received the most
immigrants uh millions and millions of
Europeans basically but also people from
um from Asia came to Argentina during
that time among them my own ancestors
from Italy and the ancestors of
basically all of us who live here today
uh because this was a country where you
could Thrive you know know where you
could uh just you know buy a piece of
land and and and work your way uh
towards the middle class and get
yourself a home and buy yourself a home
uh get a stable job and and be able to
save and and this is because Argentina
was a country that was open to the world
uh where trade international trade was
very important this was a country where
um restrictions to to economic
activities were were low uh wasn't a lot
of uh corporate
corporatism um the the the role of the
state was very limited uh public
spending was not uh super high we had no
Central Bank we had no inflation um and
we just basically welcomed anyone who
would want to come to Argentina and live
here peacefully um beginning
in that stick out to me about
Argentina's origin story is it seems
like on the Note that you're hitting
there there were also you know have been
for a long time these like little ethnic
enclaves you know with so much
immigration comes yes some amount of
assimilation and and becoming Argentine
but also at the same time sometimes
little communities of expats and there
are still these little towns in
Argentina where people speak entirely
Italian or entirely German or entirely
French or what have you and I think
there's an interesting correct me at any
point if I'm wrong but I think that
that's a really interesting thing and
then also Argentina used to be pretty
like natural resource Rich right with a
lot of Agriculture and just like so much
to export is that correct correct okay
that's correct uh in terms of um of
assimilation I would say that the you
know you having towns where people speak
a language different than Spanish that's
not something that you will find today
you could find that at the beginning of
the 20th century for sure and you can
find towns today um where you know the
the last names of everyone will be
German or you know Italian or or Spanish
correct or vice M you know like Zach or
you will find you know architecture that
is entirely Bavarian you know that's
that's actually V where the October Fest
is held of course um you you will find
uh ethnic enclaves like that but the
country um but people assimilated pretty
well I wouldn't say that there were uh
you know communities that were left out
or that decided to stay out on purpose
uh but but they they assimilated pretty
well but the the main problem begins
with the with the Great Depression and
then uh in the 1940s with the rise of
fascism because if you think about it
Argentina is the only country in the
world where 80 years after the downfall
of Nazism and fascism there is still a
very popular fascist party because Juan
pedo
was a general in the Army in the
Argentinian Army he studied under
musolini he traveled to Italy while he
uh was president and and basically in uh
put in place the same corporatist model
uh fascist model uh to manage the
country's economy right and so this is
the time where free enterprise
capitalism started to be left out
basically and
this is a time where the government
stepped in and and and this is a time
where public spending Rose where
taxation Rose where many people started
fleeing you know and capital started
fleeing this was a trend that was
opposite what had happened in the past
say 60 or 70 years uh suddenly uh people
wanted to leave the country and not come
in uh Argentina stopped receiving uh
immigration basically um and we start
started having a succession of
governments one after the other who
would fight uh because uh they claimed
that the the prior one had not been as
leftist as the new one right because
even the opposition embraced this panis
model because pism was so popular and it
was popular because Pam basically uh
handed out uh all the the money that the
country had you know uh until there was
none left and of course course there was
also no incentives for generating wealth
you know because if you're just going to
confiscate it the way he did with
nationalizations um and confiscations
and and and measures like that well of
course No One's Gonna no one's want to
want to give you anything in the future
um so yeah this is how Argentina started
falling in the indices of uh economic
freedom but also in terms of GDP per
capita for example because uh at the
beginning of the 20th century Argentina
was very similar to Australia and Canada
these these are two countries that are
also small in terms of population
they're also huge in terms of you know
uh the land they have and but the
trajectories have been very very
different Australia and Canada are you
know part of the first world if you will
today they're rich Nations uh they have
their problems but they're nowhere as
similar as Argentina where we have a
poverty rate of about 50% so Argentina
is indeed a perfect example of what
happens when you when you basically
abandon capitalism and and libertar and
liberalism in in you know in the old
sense uh and so I'm glad that that mle
talked about this at Davos and the um
that that
history likely helps explain partially
why mle is so attuned to
the ways that collectivism can come from
many different directions it can come
from parties that are more right leaning
or left leaning um and Argentina seems
like has had mixtures of both of those
things um and you know we'll get to his
definitions of collectivism in a minute
but let's roll the next clip which is
about um capitalism itself and why he
thinks that it is worth Argentina
embracing when studying per capita GDP
from 1800 to today what is observed is
that after the Industrial Revolution
Global per capita GDP multiplied by more
than 15 times generating an explosion of
wealth that lifted 90% of the world's
population out of
poverty we must never forget that by the
year 1800 about 95% of the world's
population lived in extreme poverty
while that number dropped to 5% by the
year 20 20 prior to the
pandemic the conclusion is obvious far
from being the cause of our problems
free market capitalism as an economic
system is the only tool we have to end
Hunger poverty and destitution
throughout the planet there is no doubt
that free market capitalism is Superior
in productive terms the left's DOA has
attacked capitalism for its moral issues
for being according to them as its
detractor per say
unjust they claim capitalism is bad
because it's individualistic and
collectivism is good because it's
altruistic towards
others and thus they strive for social
justice but this concept that has become
trendy in the developed World recently
in my country it has been a constant in
political discourse for over 80
years the issue is that social justice
is unfair and doesn't contribute to
General wellbeing
being on the contrary it's an inherently
unfair idea because it's violent it's
unfair because the state is financed
through taxes and taxes are collected
coercively I love the point that he's
making there which is that collectivism
is coercion collectivism is coercive
collectivism is not altruistic and for
whatever reason that mythology of
collectivism as
altruism has just seized people's
imaginations for so many decades um you
know the Young and the old alike and I
really love how Malay is just throwing
cold water on all of this and saying
absolutely not under no circumstances is
this actually the thing that truly
maximizes good this is something that
coerces other people and uses um you
know ill-gotten gains uh money stolen
via taxation to attempt to enrich the
masses in a way that frequently tramples
all over people's individual needs and
desires to me it's just the perfect
encapsulation of so much of what is
wrong with the west and he's referencing
empirical data to to support that which
is on his side you know we love our our
world in data charts here this is the
the hockey stick showing uh you know
massive growth at world GDP over uh post
industrial revolution and then of course
the uh plummeting uh share of the
population that's living in extreme
poverty um so he's he's making that
argument that empirical argument that uh
which is very well supported that uh
markets have brought uh prosperity to
the world um but then in at the same
time saying um you know the the left's
attacks on this are ill-founded uh and
based on this notion of social justice
which he thinks is flawed and I I saw a
lot of conversation and push back to his
criticism of social justice but um you
mentioned Marcos that he came with uh
you know hyek uh under his arm there and
and Hayek is also was also a staunch
critic of the concept the the idea of
social justice as at the time put
forward by people like John RS uh which
is you know the idea that um you know if
we put on a blindfold uh we want to kind
of adjust so Society so that um you know
the the veil of ignorance you not um
that that if you're at the bottom of the
hierarchy you know your life isn't
miserable and so part of the role of
government and pursuing social justice
is
to lift those people uh at the bottom
and kind of rebalance um past injustices
and yeah R theory is basically like
regardless of your station in life you
ought to be comfortable with the you
know are you comfortable with the system
uh that governs you because whether
you're a popper or peasant versus you
know you know uh CLA Schwab you ought to
you know believe that the system serves
you uh equally yeah and the critique of
that of that you know it you know
there's it's a it's a very strong
philosophical argument that that it's
it's hard to pick apart but um you know
Hayek's uh critique of this and I assume
meay he doesn't really go into it in
this speech is that um by focusing on
this this notion of social justice which
somehow never really gets uh like
concretely defined you're kind of
inviting intervention after Intervention
which then creates new injustices and
you're on this like treadmill of
constant you know rebalancing of past
injustices where true right like if you
look at what's happening in the United
States right now and I want to open the
floor up to Marcos to tell us what's
happening in Argentina and how Malay
believes this like obviously correct
thing um but like in the United States
this is what's happening right we have
the entire Legacy of of slavery and then
Jim Crow laws and racial discrimination
and you know extraordinarily horrible
treatment um of black people on the part
of white people and then what you had
was this very brief sort of Obama era of
like aspirational color blindness where
it kind of seemed like oh finally um you
know there's pretty solid racial
advancement uh of minorities and in fact
we are moving toward a system where
Perhaps it is the content of your
character and not the color of your skin
um that is actually the the you know
maybe we're moving toward a more
meritocratic society and then for
whatever reason we just scrapped all of
that and Circa 2012 2013 2014 we've
moved into this era of like very toxic
race relations where now there's you
know political correctness and wokeism
and uh Dei efforts to basically do uh
affirmative action on mass with no real
end in sight which was an interesting
thing because the Supreme Court when
issuing decision about affirmative
action years ago specifically had
liberals and conservatives on the court
who were basically saying hey maybe
affirmative action is only permissible
if we have a sort of sunset Clause built
in understanding that this is not this
should not be the permanent State of
Affairs and yet now it seems like in the
US it will be and so my my point is just
we went from having horribly fraught
race relations in the United States to
then looking like we were actually going
to move past that decently well to now
just putting Band-Aid after Band-Aid
over this thing that ends up creating
far more toxicity um being seeded by
this effort on the part of the
government generally to fix what alss
people uh is the same thing playing out
in
Argentina yeah so in Argentina we don't
really have that many uh race issues uh
itself just because we this is a pretty
homogeneous country we are receiving
immigrants this year's uh in in past
decades from neighboring countries uh
and there's sometimes you know cult
culturally different uh from us if you
will but the race uh relations aren't
really an issue but what it is an issue
is uh in terms of social justice is that
um the measures that pism that paranis
presidents but also others have taken
you know um with the goal of helping out
the poor um have backfired basically so
intervention after
intervention um has created a State of
Affairs where a a person can receive um
can basically make the same amount of
money if they are on government
subsidies uh that if they work and that
is absolutely um terrible because then
why would you want to work right if you
if you just if you can just get money
from the government and do nothing why
would anyone work and so you create you
know generations of people uh who don't
work who are used to receiving
government handouts and who will protest
if you try to take them out you know if
if you try to tell them you know um
you're gonna make less money if you stay
at home and do nothing than if you go to
work um and so that backfires you know
in in the name of social justice you
create more poverty and you create a
culture uh of a toxic culture of not
working um which is what mle is trying
to go after um but I wanted to add um
based on on what zag was was showing us
you know uh in terms of the the graphs
you know the data that mle was
referencing that I think um we we must
stress how important it is to look at
this data you know this global data and
and take a step back and look at what
capitalism has done you know in the
world in recent um centuries you know in
Greece and Millennia because here in
Argentina for example I saw when
um after mle speech I saw some people on
the left who were trying to ridicule mle
for saying that the the world had
basically not grown before uh 1800 which
is basically true if you look at the
hockey stick right um and so this is
something that people don't know Liz was
talking about you know earlier about
people protesting against the pro IMF
Zionist government of K which is total
total nonsense
but it if I could ask something to these
people is it that you know would you
prefer to to live in in this age or or
you know in in the I don't know in the
15th century like Plumbing pre- running
water and electricity and cell correct
and internet
and right it's just so basic the the
progress that Humanity has made this is
why I love taking a look at the human
prog progress website by KO too um the
progress that the humanity has made is
so remarkable that we we need to repeat
it you know all over again because
otherwise people keep complaining uh but
we but we forget how far we've come
particularly in countries like Argentina
where we have seen decline um we can't
forget the progress that other countries
have made because that's not magic
that's just you know basic economic
literacy so I just want to stress that
too no I think that's a that's an
important point to stress and it it you
know to to be fair to that you know
there are there is a group of
Libertarians who do embrace the idea of
social justice because they say that
those of us who care about this
empirical data and and point to what um
capitalism free free markets have done
ha uh are actually saying that yes if
you apply the veil of ignorance then
having markets is what will improve
Society the most and and lift up those
at the the bottom you you know you can
point to that extreme poverty chart and
say you know this is social justice um
but I guess where I start to run to
problems is that when it's applied in
the real world it's always about it
always seems to turn to well it's not
quite achieving this exact outcome and
so we need some sort of uh intervention
to rebalance the scales based on this
class class of person or that class of
person whereas Libertarians we you know
the classic way to to the the classic uh
metric or you know approach you would
use is just Justice like and Justice is
about individuals being wronged and
being made whole you can have class
action lawsuits which kind of you know
groups individuals who have all been
wronged by the same party together that
that's fine but um once you start
getting to these broad capacious terms
like social justice just it just opens
the door to all sorts of kind of
backfiring
interventions let's move on to St well
there's also another strain of
Libertarians that I think is maybe a
little softer towards social justice
because there is a sense that you know
the government has committed horrible
atrocious injustices against certain
groups and we can pretty cleanly
identify who those groups groups are
across history you know you look at
Japanese Americans being interred um in
in in concentration camps essentially in
the United States you look at uh black
descendants of slaves in the United
States and I think sometimes
Libertarians who are softer towards
social justic ISM look at that and say
well wait a second if we're in any way
consistent and principled in our
opposition to government coercion look
at the horrific coercive action that
governments have taken against these
groups of people over time but the way
in which I think they're ultimately
really wrong is that uh attempting to
solve this via other government means
based off of what we know about how
incompetent government pretty much
always is this won't actually solve the
problem nor will It ultimately quell um
people's complaints that there's sort of
some sort of grievance that they have
some sort of grievance or that there's
been some injustice perpetrated against
them right like I don't think anything
will ever fully make people whole again
and I think it's very hard to sus out
which people even need to be made whole
um and you you get sort of into a
situation where we've got we've got a
system for doing that which is is taking
things to court and so like if you're a
family that has been wronged by the
federal government your family was
interred uh during World War II or
you're a black family whose F whose land
was taken by eminent domain like there
are uh methods for achieving justice but
it has to be much more on an individual
case-by case basis rather than a blanket
approach I think yeah in a sense uh the
OG eminent domain was like you know
enslavement uh but yeah you know we can
go over that and then there's also
issues of like the government uh
promising you know 40 acres in a mule or
what have you and then failing to
deliver on certain promises throughout
time so like I can understand people's
intense rage and how that is consistent
with libertarianism or seen is
consistent with libertarianism I think
some of the trouble lies in how you
unravel um those Grievances and how you
redress them basically and I think a lot
of the times the social justice friendly
Libertarians don't answer those in a
satisfying way
let's move forward to the next part of
Malay speech which is digging into why
the West is in
Jeopardy now if free market capitalism
and economic freedom have been
remarkable instruments to eradicate
poverty globally and we are presently
experiencing the most favorable period
in human history it is worth inquiring
why I assert that the West is in
Jeopardy the main problem of the West
today is that we not only have to
confront those who even after the fall
of the wall and overwhelming evidence
continue to advocate for impoverishing
socialism but also our own leaders
thinkers and academics who sheltered in
a misguided framework undermine the
foundations of the system that has given
us the greatest wealth and prosperity in
our
history the theoretical framework I am
referring to is neoclassical economic
the issue with neoclassicals is that
since the model they fell in love with
doesn't match reality they attribute the
error to the supposed market failure
instead of revising the premises of
their Model Market is not just a
graphical description of a supply curve
and a demand curve on a
graph the market is a mechanism of
social cooperation where property rights
are voluntarily
exchanged thus considering this
definition discussing market failure is
a contradiction in
terms there is no market failure if
transactions are voluntary the only
situation in which there can be a market
failure is if there is coercion present
and the only one with the ability to
coers in a generalized manner is the
state that possesses the Monopoly of
violence each time you want to correct a
presumed market failure inevitably due
to not knowing the market or because you
have become attached to a failed model
you are opening doors to socialism and
condemning people to
Poverty so this is where he's going
right to the heart of what the WF is all
about they're they're not the WF is not
a leftist organization it is I don't
know a neoliberal or you know he calls
neoclassical um where they Embrace
markets on the whole but uh they see
lots of market failures and say that you
know there's a there's a a need for a
strong robust government intervention to
deal with those market failures things
like uh you know pollution climate
change the government needs to intervene
and Malay is saying no you're wrong
Davos crowd uh and we're going to do
things a different way in Argentina is
that more or less are we on on the same
page with like our interpretations
here um I think so yeah um I think you
know he he who was definitely critic
ized um because of this part because of
the part where he says that there can be
no market failure you know um by
neoclassical economists in Argentina uh
just because they well of course they
claim that they are and I think the
phrasing could have been differently in
that um people individually can
definitely fail in the market it's just
that you know uh there's nothing that's
that can be systemic that cannot be
solved by the market itself uh but but
you know in other than that I think um I
think your interpretation is right and I
think you know what m is saying is again
is very similar to what we have been
hearing um in Argentina it's just at
this time you know because it was in
Davos it caught you know people's eye
all over the world um so and I'm very
glad that I did because otherwise it
would have been just us you know uh
listening to to his preaching if you
will um but but but now it's all it's
also you so do you consider him to be a
sort of like high priest of Argentine
libertarianism like what do you think of
the sort of proing do you like it do you
find it creepy do you fear that he'll
develop this Cult of Personality in the
same way that many other leaders
throughout Argentine history have um I'm
I'm I'm a bit afraid of that Cult of
Personality because I think many people
follow him you know and and not the
libertarian ideas uh that he preaches
again um and and and I think that can be
that could be bad in case things go
wrong for example if he doesn't deliver
uh because then people who follow him
will not be able to criticize him
whenever he fails you know whenever he
does something that's wrong um many
people today for example I see that they
that they they don't want to criticize
the government because of anything even
if they make mistakes you know uh just
because they want to they want to
support me all the way I don't think
that's that's very healthy um because
that can lead him to believe that he can
you know do whatever um I do believe of
course he's a Libertarian and I I have
confidence I mean I voted for him like
all the times you know in the primaries
and the general election in the runoff
and I would vote for him again um but I
want him to you know be uh faithful you
know to to the libertarian idea uh in
that regard I think he was more like a
priest when he was campaigning again
he's not talking much right now I think
that's very strategic I think he has
definitely adapted to being president
which is a good thing because there was
this you know concern that that Zach was
talking about earlier that he would be
you know like Trump and he would just
keep talking um as president all the
time and and doing nothing um but mle is
not one of those um I think he he is
like strategically receding you know
from the public high as the nasty you
know job gets done basically uh because
of course you know raising revenue for
the government is something that you
know would be Unthinkable under a
Libertarian government but again his
priority now is to stabilize the country
you know avoid hyperinflation and then
you know um transform the country um so
I think that's why he's not talking much
but he can if things you know turn right
for him if he is able to deliver if if
this law that he's um sending out to
Congress gets passed and and we start to
see a recovery you know an economic
recovery in future months I think he can
be he can go back to the you know to the
priest role uh from which he has receded
in recent
months it's it's going to be interesting
because he's staking out such this is a
very doctrinaire libertarian position
that really differentiates him from the
kind of more
liberal governance that the WF would
suggest where he's saying literally
there's no such thing as a market
failure um you know this I uh and and so
it's kind of like where the policy
rubber meets the road for a Libertarian
because there will be situations
where uh some sort of voluntary
transaction results in
uh an externality it results in
something that costs other people
something and kind of the the doctrin
libertarian approach to that as well
they should be compensated through they
should be able to bring a suit they
should be able to bring a Tor through
the courts and get compensated for that
um that's not at all how the modern
world is governed we're governed via
regulation to uh avoid those that that
kind of extreme liability from like an
oil spill or um air pollution or
something like that so it's going to be
I think an where it's like something to
watch and kind of like empirically
observe like you know it first of all
will mle be able to to apply that in
Argentina which we can talk about later
because we can get into the politics but
then if he
does what happens when some sort of
environmental cost is is
incurred um let's go to the next the
next uh clip let's keep let's keep
forging ahead uh and this one is where
Malay starts to get into the culture
wars a little bit which we've heard him
weigh in on in the
past libertarianism already establishes
equality between Sexes the Cornerstone
of our Creed states that all men are
created equal that we all have the same
unalienable rights granted by the
Creator among which are life liberty and
property this radical feminism agenda
has led to increased State intervention
hindering the economic process it
provides jobs to bureaucrats who haven't
contributed anything to society whether
through women's Ministries or
International organizations promoting
this
agenda another conflict that socialist
pose is that of humans against nature
they argue that hum humans cause harm to
the planet and that it must be protected
at all costs even advocating for
population control mechanisms or
supporting the controversial agenda of
abortion
rights unfortunately these harmful ideas
have strongly permeated our
society neo-marxists have managed to
co-op the common sense of the Western
World they achieved this through the
appropriation of the media culture
University and yes even International
organizations the final case is very
serious as it involves institutions with
huge influence on the political and
economic decisions of the countries in
these multilateral
organizations fortunately more of us
dare to raise our voices as we see that
if we don't confront these ideas headon
the only possible Destiny is more State
more regulation more socialism more
pover poverty less freedom and
consequently a worse quality of
life so maybe this is me giving into the
feminist agenda Liz but I want you to
take this first given kind of how that
clip started off well I tend to go back
to the old uh like Ruth Bader Ginsburg
line amusingly uh which is like I ask
essentially I ask for no special favors
um all I ask is that my brethren take
their their feet uh off my neck uh and
it's very much I think the thing that's
interesting is that today's feminist
movement has sort of yassifieds
ified the Ruth beer Ginsburg um
mythology into something that like she
didn't actually believe she was
legitimately this very old school second
wave feminist type that's just like
equality between the Sexes that's all
you need you don't really need special
treatment beyond that and that's where I
stand I mean I don't feel as though my
life is made in any way um worse by Dent
of being a lady in the United States
states in the developed world I mean
that's just a laughable premise to me
and I'm really sick of um a lot of uh
female complaining to that effect I
don't think there needs to be any sort
of government intervention on my behalf
to attempt to secure uh any sort of
special treatment for me I mean I I have
a wonderful life and I don't need the
state to be involved in any way I also
tend to agree with Malay on issues like
abortion I mean him talking about the
population control agenda and the degree
to which abortion is very socially um
you know permissible in I know in Latin
America it tends to be regarded a little
bit differently though Argentina I think
is perhaps in some ways more in line
with the United States here but like I I
Don't Feel Free by um being allowed to
exercise my right to kill my fetus uh up
until week 24 or 25 in the state of New
York where I live I don't feel free uh
doing that I think many other women
disagree with me but you know I see that
as an innocent rights sparing individual
that I believe the state has a
compelling interest uh in protecting and
I believe that feminism can uh be
consistent with that belief and I feel
empowered by being a mom and joyful so
you know I'm a little bit of a Malay
stand on this front you guys might
disagree Marcos it seems like the the
economics has obviously taken the front
burner at the beginning of malle's
administration here like does do these
cultural issues still are they still
like how at play are they in Argentina
at this
point uh well some of them definitely
resonate um I wouldn't say that the the
ecological agenda is much important I
don't think it is although what what M
says I think is very important you know
because it is often you know assumed
that the planet has rights you know uh
but you know if you take a step back and
think about it you're like well is that
right like isn't it humans who have
rights I mean we can debate you know
which what rights we have which ones we
don't what what is a right but but does
the planet have rights I mean can we do
can we take measures you know coercively
with the force of the State uh in in the
name of the planet that will harm humans
um that that's if you put it that way
you know it's it's very interesting and
I like that rhetorical you know uh
phrasing that the way that he presents
these issues um in terms of feminism uh
I think that that's an agenda that
resonates more here in Argentina um mle
has been at least partially
consequential uh with his speech because
he demoted uh the the ministry uh for
women uh that had been created by the
former president um by former president
Alberto Fernandez uh there was a
Ministry um the number of bureaucrats
had
skyrocketed uh in that Ministry uh there
was public spending wasn't super high
compared to other expenses but it was
still you know sizable what did the
do well um that's a good question I
would say they they focused more on you
know holding seminars and you know
conversations and then bringing people
together and talking basically about you
know L tea parties andu yeah correct
correct yeah yeah yeah but but you know
there were also some like mini scandals
you know like I don't know I remember
one time um someone um someone said and
it was true you know we everyone got to
see the the the invoices afterwards that
the ministry was buying um trash cans
you know at like 10 times the price uh
the market price so like you know it was
just basically used to spend money uh
hire a lot of people who um as M said
don't contribute to the the economy but
also not necessarily to solving a
problem um even if that problem is real
you know the problem of violence against
women although there's also violence
against men uh but I mean uh mle has
been consequential he shut down the
ministry of of women he can't he cannot
do much about employees per se uh
because public employees are guaranteed
stability in their jobs here in
Argentina so that's that's tough that's
very tough for any president who wants
to fire people basically um because they
can only fire the people who they who
have been hired um for a short term you
know for a defined period of time
otherwise they can't do anything but at
least the ministry uh is shut down um
and then that there's this question this
lingering question on abortion we don't
really know what's going to happen with
abortion abortion is legal in Argentina
it has been so since uh
2018 um it is free also you can you can
have an abort an abortion at a public
Hospital uh and private hospitals are
forced to perform abortions even if they
even religious even Catholic Hospitals
that yes and that has that was one of
the points uh of the law that was you
know the most criticized uh back when
the law was passed um but you know mle
received a lot of support from Pro
movements um and for many of these uh
movements abortion is the key and and
maybe the only issue that they care
about so I anticipate that there will be
renewed discussion on abortion Argentina
um maybe not this year but next year I
think the priority right now is the
economy I think the government is smart
enough uh to to concentrate all of their
efforts on the economy but it's some
point I think there's going to be uh
inside pressure from within the
government uh to reopen you know the
discussion well one thing I wanted to
ask you about Marcos is okay so years
ago I was in medine in Colombia and I
stumbled across a thing that I had never
seen before um which was an abortion
related protest in the streets with
attractive young women who seemed Urban
educated well-dressed Etc and you know
some older woman too and my I didn't
know Spanish very well then I honestly
still don't now um but my first uh
assumption was that they were are you
know protesting in favor of making you
know allowing abortion in favor of
pro-choice in favor of abortion rights
um then I talked with some of them and
learned actually no it was just this
massive pro-life rally um which sort of
demographically was confusing to me
because I've never seen you know you
wouldn't go to the streets of Manhattan
or Brooklyn and see a bunch of women
wearing um you know nice clothes who
went to you know Ivy League schools or
whatever who are advocating who are
Marching In the streets in favor of the
pro-life cause against abortion rights
right so you know that's obviously a
different situation like Colombia Mexico
Argentina Chile I know they all have
their own distinct on the ground culture
surrounding abortion but what's that
Dynamic like in Argentina is there a
significant contingent of like women my
age who are in that pro-life Camp who
are vocal about it or is it pretty
monolithic where people of a certain um
sort of type um from certain places
regionally sort of map cleanly onto the
pro-choice or pro-life cause like tell
me about what it looks like there so I I
would say that Argentina resembles um
the US rather than Colombia at least in
this respect it is usually you know if
you find a um
I mean if you find people protesting on
the street and they look like they're
you know middle class or upper middle
class or they're likely to be in favor
of abortion but there are also some
circles you know some traditional like
particularly in the city of buiders you
know very traditional uh Catholic
circles where there's strong opposition
to abortion uh from from you know the
upper class you will find those people
too but usually if you see a
demonstration against abortion it will
be people um who you know are are not as
wealthy as the ones who are protesting
in favor of it but but you can have
these mixtures you can definitely have
it's not as monolithic perhaps as in the
US uh but it's also not as upside down
as it can be in in Colombia interesting
yeah that's definitely I almost wonder
whether there's like a Continuum that
could be created of different um
countries in Latin America and the
degree to which they do or do not model
the us on this because I've paid a
little bit of attention to abortion
politics in Mexico and I'm really
curious about how that's going to shake
out especially because in a lot of these
countries that we've mentioned you know
in the United States we saw the Dos
decision um a little bit ago a few years
ago that reversed essentially 50 years
of roie Wade being the law of the land
where abortion was broadly permitted
with fewer um restrictions placed on it
in many cases with abortions allowed up
until you know the end of the second
trimester uh in many many states um
later point in pregnancy than many other
countries around the world but the thing
that's really interesting is we've seen
in a lot of Latin American countries
it's only been in the last five years or
so that abortion has been made legal in
a lot of these places um and that's sort
of an interesting like I'm curious about
what the that Dynamic will look like
going forward and to some degree it's
like the right feels less enduring and
less entrenched if you know it was only
sort of enshrined in law within the last
few years that's something that can
still very much be changed I think and I
mean the political results of Dos here
in the US have been very mixed for uh
actually I would say negative for uh
Republicans because uh you know these uh
it turns out uh lowering the limits to
abortion to you know a few weeks is not
very popular here um and uh I that that
you know if Argentina's going to uh uh
roll it back Countrywide like you know
that would be very different than what
happened here in the US where it was
kicked back to the States and um I
imagine there would be quite a quite a
backlash to that kind of move we've also
SE an interesting um backlash an
interesting thing in the United States
which is where the mechanism by which
these rights are decided has sort of as
it's become as the right has become
imperil the mechanism by which people
are looking to decide it has shifted
like we saw saw instead of this being
decided at the legislature level or via
you know executive order we've seen like
in Kansas for example the Constitutional
amendment being added uh and people
coming to the polls to vote on this so
then basically you have this backlash
effect where people are enshrining this
in a more enduring way which I think is
kind of the opposite of what a lot of
pro-life Republicans thought would
happen yeah for sure um and then on you
know stepping away from abortion for a
second on on the culture War Front
um I do wonder if melay could uh be
someone to chart a course on like what a
Libertarian version of engaging in these
uh looks like and how it differs from
the conservative version because he does
seem to be pretty focused on just like
the government agencies I mean he even
says in that statement like Libertarians
are fully for equality between the Sexes
for equality before the law and you know
all all these issues we talked about
earlier uh with um you know the the
history of Black Americans or Japanese
Americans like redressing all of those
grievances is a tough thing to do and it
it h like it it's something we're still
coping with here in America and that has
to play out um in the social realm and
and that might involve different uh
affirmative action schemes or whatnot at
at the in the in private sector but the
more that we uh entrench this in the
public sector just it seems like the
more
divisive uh it it it's becoming in
America you're you're continually
dividing people into these official
government categories and Malay is on a
mission to undo that in Argentina and
it's maybe something for American
Libertarians to uh keep an eye on his
his approach to that um we we have a
couple more Clips to get through uh
let's go to his next one which is on
socialism and what he says is the
Socialist takeover of the
West to many it may sound ridiculous to
suggest that the West has embraced
socialism but this view is only
ridiculous if one limits themselves to
the traditional economic definition of
socialism which states that it is an
economic system
where the state owns the means of
production today states don't need to
control means of production to control
every aspect of individuals
lives with tools such as monetary
issuance debt subsidies interest rate
control price controls and regulations
to correct alleged market failures they
can control the Destinies of millions of
human
beings this is how we have reached a
point where with different names or
forms good parts of the politically
accepted offers in most Western
countries are generally collectivist
variants whether they openly declare
themselves as Communists fascists Nazis
socialists social Democrats National
socialists Christian democrats keans
neans progressives populists
nationalists or globalists in the end
there are no substantive differences
everyone argues that the state should
control all aspects of individuals lives
if if measures are adopted that hinder
the free functioning of markets free
competition free Price systems if trade
is hindered if private property is
attacked the only possible destination
is
poverty so th this goes back to what we
were talking about a little bit earlier
the mle kind of broadly defining uh
collectivism and putting all these
different variants of collectivism into
one bucket it it reminds me of uh of the
highx uh thrust in the road to serfdom
the idea that uh once you start down the
road of excessive planning um you end up
in a really bad place regardless of kind
of the political packaging that it's in
whether that's right or left wing um
anything else to say on that portion
before we move to the final Malay clip
Marcos oh I want to listen to the final
one I want to know I want to find out
which one you picked as the final one
okay this is his closing statement uh
let's see how Malay uh wrap this
up to summarize I want to convey a
message to all entrepreneurs present
don't be intimidated by the political
cast or the parasites who live off the
state don't yield to a a political class
that only wants to prolong its power and
preserve its
privileges you are social benefactors
you are heroes you are the creators of
the most extraordinary era of prosperity
we have ever
experienced don't let anyone say
ambition is immoral if you earn money
it's because you provide a superior
product Better Price contributing to
well-being do not yield to the advance
of the state the state is not the
solution the state is the problem itself
you are the true protagonists of this
story and know that from today you have
Argentina as an unconditional
Ally thank you very much and long life
Freedom Dam
it long life Freedom damn it that is uh
that is uh you know all my phone
calls every time I get off the phone
yeah a very IR Rand ending to that uh
how does that make you feel Liz I'm I
mean I feel um extraordinary Joy
swelling deep within my soul every time
I hear Malay say long live Freedom dbb
it um no I mean I think it's it
definitely strikes objectivist tones at
the very end and I think it's actually
how insane is it that this stands out to
such a degree because we've had so few
great communicators for the idea that
like no uh greed is good um maybe not in
such uh sort of brusk blunt terms but to
some degree I think it's important to
sometimes call a parasite a parasite a
leech a leech and to say you know we
don't need to have this parasitic
relationship with the state we should
not have countries that have that type
of system if you want to pursue making
the best possible product and selling it
to willing consumers do that that's a
good thing that's a cool thing that's an
honest and admirable thing I think in
the US we saw this bubble up a little
bit uh in the sort of 2013 to 2015 era I
know Arthur Brooks has been a huge
proponent of this the former president
of AI um he wrote that wonderful book
called the conservative heart and very
much espouses this gospel preaches to
use your word Marcus um this idea of no
it's actually totally consistent with
being a good and moral and honorable
person to believe that um you know
pursuing uh making money and pursuing
voluntary means of organizing and
pursuing things out far outside of the
State trying to um you know make as much
money as possible and then being very
charitable uh with how you use it and
not expecting the government to be
fixing all of the problems but rather
thinking about more creative and more
efficient ways of solving that in your
communities that's a good thing and
that's something we need to see so much
more of um so I kind of love the degree
to which Malay is really disabusing
people of the notion that the only way
to be an altruistic moral good person is
to favor the state giving people
handouts there are so many other ways to
be an altruistic and moral person and I
think people like us would probably say
that favoring um redistributive means of
providing for the poor ends up not
actually providing for the poor and it
ends up coercing a lot of people in the
process there is a better way and for
whatever reason uh a lot of people
really struggle to articulate that I
think Ein Rand articulated that a little
bit but in a pretty obnoxious and
horrible way and I think Malay is
frankly doing a much better job
and he's uh yeah it's like he's uh
telling all the business uh men in that
business people in that audience you
know don't give in to the Temptation
don't uh you know Embrace this WF like
quote unquote cooperation between uh the
private and public like you need to uh
just embrace your your inner
entrepreneur and he's also buttering
them up a little bit right like he's
doing a little bit of that it's a
rejection of of crony capitalism which
is uh what you wrote about in an article
uh uh kind of giving the overview of
mala's early days uh Marcos you called
it Argentina's offensive against crony
capitalism which we will link uh in the
description here but maybe we could
close out this uh conversation with you
just kind of recapping that like why why
is mle on an offensive again like why is
crony capitalism really ultimately
what's in his crosshairs
right um well I think he is going
against crony capitalism because he
understands that capitalism is supposed
to be um based on free enterprise and
that you know um entrepreneurs are
social benefactors like he said in this
you know randesi uh closing uh speech um
but um that's one thing I liked about I
mean I like that I like the speech
overall but I like that part in
particular because he's telling
entrepreneurs you know uh businessmen to
not be ashamed of themselves basically
because this is a question of guilt you
know that why do they do this why do
they Embrace collectivism if they have
been so popular you know um by by
playing by the book and and many times
it's because they're guilty at least
this is what we have seen in Argentina
of course there's also people who have
you know um stolen wealth basically from
the people because the government has
allowed them to do so through monopolies
and you know privileges regulations and
right now mle is going against this is
he's going against pry capitalism
because he's trying to open up markets
in different aspects you know he's
trying to um for example he he's trying
to liberate the housing market which in
Argentina had been uh virtually um you
know shut down because of reg ulations
nobody wanted to put you know an
apartment out for rent uh because you
know you you you weren't able to um you
weren't able to update you know the the
the the fees that you charge in one year
in an economy rent control on it they
had rent control in an economy with 200%
inflation you know that's absolutely
insane but melee is is going against
corent capitalism because he is
basically trying to uh tell the
businessmen that have lived off of
government support you know you are done
this is over I mean we need to um we
need to move forward and the the and and
the the the people need to to be able to
profit you know not not just companies
because of regulations and privileges so
for example he's imposing an open SKU
policy
and he's rejecting uh price minimums
that were designed basically to benefit
Adas which is the the state uh the
government owned uh airlin most terrible
Airline on the planet exactly which in
ficient which loses hundreds of millions
of dollars a year and this hurt lowcost
Airlines and so it was people you know
regular people were being uh forced to
pay more to fly um but there's other
examples there's um the the there was
the national wine making policy law you
know which um set um maximum prices uh
for wine producers which limited you
know the amount of wine that they
produced in a country which is supposed
to export wine you know um we even had
um something that was called like the
supermarket shelf law you know which
regulated how products needed to be
displayed in supermarkets like literally
you know so that there would be always
you know 30% for Argentine products and
basically telling consumers what to do
you know um unions for example unions
were allowed to keep money to retain
money uh from uh employees who didn't
even want to be
unionized um if they wanted to uh opt
for Private health care for example
because UN in Argentina unions offer
Health Care by themselves but you can
opt out of that but if you opt out of
that before M decree if you wanted to
opt out uh of the Union provided Health
Care System the union would still keep
money just for transferring out that
money to a private insurance so it's wow
dozens hundreds of regulations like this
you know the the regulation that says
that supermarkets cannot sell aspirins
because it is only pharmacists who can
do it you know it's an am an insane
amount of
regulations uh that were overturned by
the decree or they are likely to be
overturned by the omnus bill um and
which is you know the core of mle's
agenda today he's going against Cent
capitalism and he means it I hope he
means it I hope all these things change
and I hope that you know it is the
consumers who benefit from capitalism
and not cronies not the friends of
government and every single one of those
thousands of regulations or privileges
that he's going after just pisses off
some special interest which likely
explains why we're now seeing this
massive mobilization in the streets and
be keeping an eye on that and on all the
developments and hope that you'll come
back and uh keep us updated on what's
going on there Marcos
thank you Zach and thank you Liz also
yes thank you and uh thanks for everyone
who tuned in we will see you back here
next
week thanks for listening to just asking
questions these conversations appear on
reason's YouTube channel and the just
asking questions podcast feed every
Thursday subscribe wherever you get your
podcasts and please rate and review the
show